and that's what we like to see out of Branch
it in a firing machine ni G it across to the
near side for McKinnon shot and he'll get it back
on the far side you saw Corella make the push all
the way over to stop McKinnon there's a shot score
Nathan M kinon sneaking inside the near post Coro
could not make that push and all of a sudden the
apps have the one nothing lead McKinnon's streaks
continue 17th straight overall that ties for Tops
this year in the National Hockey League Moes is
poetry in motion the entire first shift the entire
power play was just beautiful Nik Raton winning
Puck battles great shots look at that little give
and go from Jonathan Drew wi kale Mar back up on
the point pass and an opportunity for the SS to
get one on net set down deep intercepted by MC
he'll look ahead bangs it up fight here comes CT
in a backand to the slot and his shot his save by
po pelo he's a coaching weapon we get a chance we
watch the games together and I'll hold you to that
Norris back up top for his defenseman sta dishes
off Puck to the near side score and that was a
little too easy as Norris is able to bang it home
for his 11th of the Season into a wide open goal
mouth young superstars and I will say that for
this Ottawa Senator team as we watch just kind of
the breakdown wide open on that back door gear had
no chance to get over just a nice passing play by
Ottawa but as a 21-year-old Mo Norris had 35 goals
last season but if the S could just put all their
p's and q's together this could be a a playoff
team there's no doubt well I think they're going
to be I just don't know if that the whole they've
dug this year might be too big to get out of in
the East I think you're probably right about that
off the stick deflected hit Tes in the back score
oh my goodness gracious the Ottawa Senators have
taken a 2-1 lead that puck went up in the air and
it looks like a Ridley Greg is going to pick
up his fourth Puck go to the point so we got
a good play in the offensive zone everybody's in
position the harmless shot at net goes up and over
off the back of Devon and lands right on Ridley
Greg stick so you tell me how this works right
up and over off the back it literally wheels
off his leg like Plinko from the Price's you
have got to be kidding me moments yes and this is
the way it's going through the ABS what can go in
the back of your net is going in the back of the
net it's unbelievable Here Comes nuski trying to
power his way around Sanderson shoots s corasado
and he boots that one away as teras senko will
scoot that one up and out ABS collected again
MC had to reach and he's just so good at that
he'll turn it straight up the gut swings it up
to the further net wood shoots it a safe by cor
pello I don't think that nik's actually trying
to put it through the dead minder I think what
he's trying to do is when Corella makes his push
he opens some spots that that puck can find its
way through Zu can hang on and the SL shot SC
Nathan canon his second goal of period number
one his 16th of the season and the ABS needed
that in the horse cut away well we said before
the game jokingly he's the Rudolph for this team
right now and he's leading that slay Fuller being
the Avalanche keeping them in the game two goals
on the night that's a greasy one we haven't seen
him score one in front sticks all around getting
an ugly one in a while but they all count for
McKinnon ABS feeling it here tonight want to
make a statement on the home ice but they've
been so successful watch out down low DS
left save by Goran and that was brilliant
again another broken play that shot as you said
rer off the ear is about the ear shoulder area
up top long shot deflected score right through the
five hole of Alexander gor of on the redir looks
like celik is going to get credit for this one
it'll be his first goal of the Season eventually
say uncle so the ABS lose a face off that's step
one okay usually can handle that and then right
in front his Kale's trying to break up the plate
we'll get a real good look at it here it's right
on the ice and kale just tries to grab that Puck
and accidentally deflects it perfectly through
gor here's a real good look kale puts stick down
now it's molinsky and wrist shot save cor as got
dumped down that was olivon harded the front of
the net and zo walks it into the corner finally
finds noris ABS taken away now a run s Corpus
Salo Point Blank redirected by drwan and that
one through the top of the crease Greg able to
send it ahead kachuck able to get it free down
the the slot watch out shot save by gorf he
robed Parker Kelly and they're playing well
I'm with you m it feels like they're controlling
play a little bit watch out another two onone shot
save by gorv tereno a save by Goran little lack
to be desired on that one two shots on goal on
it fire to Center Ice cut down by teras senko
gets it across shot scor bson able to put it
past gorv and that one stings with 5 minutes
and 13 seconds to go and he just looked awkward
pass across by tereno and Bs 20 goals last year
that's his 11th this season but watch gur if he
comes across and he's way hugging that right
post I think he went to push off on the right
foot and he missed and then Bon had a whole
bunch of net see the right foot M how it's way
almost McKinnon is in NuSkin back to kale marar
with 42 to go in the power play plenty of time
ranted it can buy one cross I shot save Corell
it's batted away shot score M Ranon the Moose
finally gets loose and unloads for a power play
goal they cut the Gap it's now a 4-3 game well
it turns out that it is 4x6 for M ran after
narrowly missing off the crossbar 30 seconds
to go quick little shot over to McKinnon
he gets the rebound and just slings it at
the in any sort of meaningful way with 48 to go
on the power play no shots on goal R and will
wheel ahead not cut off he'll Chas himself all
the way around Val fell down but kept it alive
finds Taves now it's McKinnon fake the onetime
first shot he scores Nathan M kenon with a the
hatrick and the ABS have tied the game in four
on his power play goal as mckinon rewards his
team career goal 301 his 17th of the season
and what's amazing is he held off on the slap
shot that means Corpus Alo gets set he slides
it right over the shin pad of the defender NE
confuses Corella I don't think it C the shin P
Watch here as it comes across no way cut down
to the ice glove down by m down the boards for
thein wanted to give it back it does so the a
are now reset mckinon was calling for that puck
he'll find kale straight away AC mckinon it go
find r m r in the little rear at from the goal
line extended and the as have taken a 5-4 lead
Ron in second of the game his 17th of the Season
it is red red hot now watch McKinnon he sells his
shot and that's the key me goes way far over I
don't think I've ever seen him score this far
over on that deflection shot that's got to come a
long ways oh corello had no idea that was coming
he was ready for that McKinnon shot and just
a perfect little surprise tip set up to the
Blue Line rammed off for jaru in the slot shot SL
Bucky get with the left toe his left B and he has
clear it down here's McKinnon looking for his for
you're Ador r j score Nathan M Kennon reading the
hash marks and then here it is Nathan McKinnon
to cap off a four goal 59 H played by Johansson
into the Avalanche Zone with five to go Kelly
could not Center it and that will do it here at
poena